[Music]
foreign
Casey confused it with Jakarta Indiana
good thing this random Hostess knows who
Dr radna is what would the officers have
done if she didn't I mean don't get me
wrong I'm glad this actor got paid to do
some pointing but that doesn't make the
sequence of events any less confusing
just finishing she still had bread left
you didn't let her eat the bread you are
monsters and nothing can convince me
otherwise
then could you at least give her a hint
as to why you've abducted her okay I'm
guessing the military doesn't want to
cause a panic but this guy seems more
interested in creating attention for us
than making sure this poor woman doesn't
feel like she's about to be executed for
an overdue parking violation walking
walking
excitement this is a cool visual for the
audience but why is the professor of
mycology doing this sure she would be
there to review the results but
shouldn't a pathologist or an
upholsterer be the one to check the
corpse stuffing choosing to own a couch
of this color
in the [__] head admittedly I don't
know anything about the Indonesian
police force but I would hope that in
almost every situation a bullet lobotomy
is in option number one
yeah but until today also thought there
was no way the cordyceps could live
inside a human body so isn't there at
least a chance that this new strain
could have some vulnerabilities
look I know this is deliberately extreme
but the fear of fungus among us but who
goes from four deaths and maybe 14 cases
unaccounted for to bombing an entire
city those 14 missing people may not
even be infected there's playing it safe
and then there's blowing up the planet
to make sure it doesn't get hit by an
asteroid do I look like I'm infected
judging cordyceps by its cover it's
what's inside the counts Ellie she found
me after I Was Bitten and she didn't
shoot you clearly not Ellie would infect
all of us with laughter at TV sins
thank you
they're out a few pages Tess is
suggesting that this 20 year old
magazine might make for good wiping
material and I would argue that anything
from the Moss beneath her feet to not
wiping at all would be more hygienic
good night just doesn't matter but I
mean it kinda does right man Joel's
pessimism is really starting to take a
toll on Tess and I really think she was
on The Fringe of figuring something very
important out here is it chicken
whatever it is I have very serious
Stouts there's a refrigerated section in
Ellie's backpack so it's most likely a
future case of food poisoning whatever
happened to me to find in the vaccine
that's what this is we've heard this a
million times okay Joel professor of
mycology Texas Miller but have you ever
heard this from someone who is living
proof of immunity or at the very least
someone who survived after being bitten
for longer than you thought possible
also why are Joel and tests so surprised
that's what this is she's a 14 year old
kid who appears to be immune to bites
from the infected how could they not
know she was going to be used to help
find a cure I guess the test just said
her and Joel aren't good people but
they're fairly smart people right also
also why the [__] does Joel care anyway
as Tess is about to rightly say you're
not getting the gear you need in
exchange for a vaccine you're getting
the gear for delivering Ellie so what
difference does it make if they can turn
her into an anti-fungal cream or not
this isn't gonna end
[Music]
and give them food poisoning too they've
already got a fungal infection alley no
reason to make their situation worse
it's a good movie yeah you can start by
running up that road running up that
hill be running up that building
apparently the pitch for Last of Us was
just like The Walking Dead But much less
of the exciting dead stuff and much more
of the walking long way or short way I
mean it's the long way or the whiff and
dead way which makes me wonder why Joel
suggested thee or [__] dead way how
did you get fit you know the old Malden
accusing didn't think there was going to
be anything in there and then one just
came at me out of nowhere I feel like
there's a lot more to Ellie's origin
story than we're being told and I hate
being teased like this the main story
confidently progresses on proud of the
seed it's planted well I just feel left
behind well I mean you got some balls on
your sister using the male reproductive
parts is the symbol of Courage without
considering everything the female
reproductive parts have to go through or
have go through them or ones with spit
open
dark like that
great time to explain how that
particular fun guy likes to behave at
parties they clearly know it's a thing
and considering it hunts based on sound
waiting until it turns up is a pretty
idea if you need to explain that it
hunts based on sound show teases us with
a piano playing frog only to never show
it again this is so gross everyone's
respective orifices survive this funky
pond water
Part of Me loves Ellie's childish
playfulness but another part of me
thinks she should be smarter than to
make unnecessary noises in a place that
she can in no way guarantee doesn't have
mushroom monsters present so yes ma'am
ding ding indeed yes ma'am would you
like me straight through luggage yes
ma'am right away man you're a weird kid
no this is exactly how kids work and
Joel having had one should really know
this
one thing I can tell you for certain I
really hope this is the last of the jump
scares because if it's not it definitely
won't be the last of the jump scare sins
kicking a person while they're dead
let's try climbing some [__] floors
with our knees see how you feel then may
I be so bold as to suggest using your
feet for the next flight maybe I could
climb up there work my way around
and open it from the inside or you could
break the doors down I mean in video
games would indoor stop you because
Beyond them lies the nothingness void of
a matrix yet to be programmed but in the
real world that's almost never the case
it's a bit of a mess so I'm gonna need a
few minutes feel free to take this time
to bond or create further tension
between yourself and your co-lead
whatever feels natural where'd you learn
to do that the circus is the knife
flipping really that impressive or is
Joel just making small talk because Joel
should be harder to impress and or
should hate Small Talk worry from Texas
Texas what about tests Detroit it's in
Michigan I go to school I know where
Detroit is the depressing fact that
making this statement in our version of
2023 doesn't necessarily guarantee
knowing things good to see that the U.S
school system may have actually improved
thanks to the apocalypse how long do
infected live there's others been
walking around for 20 years how does
Joel know this for certain in the chaos
of the Apocalypse I can't imagine
there's been a lot of opportunity to
track or carbon date the infected or has
he seen a few walking around wearing an
I went to 2003 and all I got was this
lousy fungal infection t-shirt what
about that guy
fortunately test arrives just in time to
prevent us from learning anything truly
meaningful about Joel's character now
that might seem harsh but some insight
into whether or not he feels remorse for
beating that guard to death would have
been pretty powerful and since a little
birdie told me we never come back to the
subject it either feels like a wasted
opportunity or one the writers didn't
want to flesh out what now
okay she didn't say the words but that
expression had you better come take a
look at this cliche written all over it
I see you Tess I see you they're
connected more than you know this shot
and the following explanation of how the
cordyceps work is so [__] cool a
quick accept your sin removal before I
change my mind in Addison for any
nightmares this will inspire yeah
cooked finally some [__] luck
premature quarticep liberation
or maybe you found a way to travel
through time which involved covering
himself in Jam running through a museum
and peeling his own skin you see he's
not really dead his Consciousness is
just returned to 2003 to prevent all of
this from happening or you could not
assume the best and get the [__] out of
their tests
[Music]
wouldn't this have been a good plan a
Joel also is silent to even an option
Sound Works through vibration and that's
going to be caused by every clunky boot
every squeaky floorboard and every
single breath if silence is what's
required to survive here then I'd
suggest you find another route or Sandra
Bullock
kids
really feel like this is information
that could have been brought to Ellie's
attention yes
yes
my pants
hello Ramsay man
out of here why hasn't this already
happened there's no way of knowing if
they got them all so why are they
hanging around and talking as if they
couldn't be 10 more ready to pop out and
deprive us of what little anators we
have remaining over there yeah I know it
looks scary
that was scary this is wood being this
casual about wood this wood looks pretty
old which means you could get splinters
and then an infection and then no I
don't know fall a thousand feet to your
death is it everything you hope for
asking this after only two episodes I'm
gonna have to at least see some giraffes
before I make that kind of judgment and
it's not like episode three is gonna be
one of the greatest episodes of
Television ever created with some of the
most incredibly nuanced performances but
to film now will it
they went inside
what is Tess so pissed about that the
truck people went inside or is it where
they parked the truck it's probably the
ladder this gets it I mean one of them's
got to have a map on them right even if
they do it doesn't mean it'll be helpful
unless Tess thinks there'll be a giant
red x that marks the spot of where Ellie
was supposed to be headed have you even
ever mapped before Tess because I don't
think you have [__]
she's infected I'm sorry Tess but dick
move that bite is about as close to the
brain as it gets which means she only
has a couple of hours before becoming
servopolis Al fungi so she really should
have told Joel and Ellie straight away
regardless she definitely should have
mentioned it before entering a building
that she hoped was filled with fireflies
also while killing off test sends the
message that no character on the series
is safe I'm still pretty pissed off that
I only got two in a tour filled episodes
that's in a [__] dwarf
throwing hand grenades into the marinade
of fuel at the feet of Humanity's Only
Hope for survival
you are and you should be and if you
want me to like your character more
Ellie then stop being such a [__] kid
kid
[Music]
and of course the lighter doesn't work
and by that I mean it won't work for all
of the predictable amounts of tension
building sometime until it suddenly does
work
fungalingus I'm sure this shot much like
the last shot of the first episode means
something if you played the game but I
haven't played the game and therefore
this is just 30 seconds of unneeded
post-apocalyptic building porn and I
hate porn
wait
I was made in the mannequin Factory in
Poughkeepsie I never shot a wild beast
is that chicken silent breed is people
bam I'm eight years old you think I'd be
here alone I don't think so but when we
get to 20 tell me I'm gonna throw up
foreign
that's Jason Bourne give me some sugar
baby